التوتر على الحدود بين لبنان واسرائيل
رفقته اتهامات اسرائيليه للبنانيين بتخريب
حاجز حدودي ودفع بمزارع الشبع ومنطق مناطق
مجاوره الى الواجهه وتقع مزارع شبعه وتلال
كفر شوبا المحتله على الحدود بين لبنان
والجزء المحتل من الجولان السوري تمتاز
بموقع جغرافي استراتيجي كونها تقع عند
مثلث الحدود اللبنانيه السوريه
الاسرائيليه وتعتبرها بيروت اراضيه
لبنانيه محتله تخضع المزارع للقرار الدولي
رقم 497 وتنتشر فيها قوات الامم المتحده
لمراقبه فض الاشتباك
للمتابعه معنا من عمان الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي اللواء فايز الدويري لواء
الدويري قراءتك لهذا التوتر الان هل يتعلق
الامر بحادث معزول
هذه المنطقه هي نقطه اشتعال
ومنذ عام 1970 ودخلت القوات الاسرائيليه
خمس مرات في عام السبعين 72 75 76 78
وبقيت فيها حتى عام 2000 وعندما انسحبت
وتم رسم ما اطلق عليه بخط الانسحاب او
الخط الازرق كان هناك 13 تحفظ لبناني على
بعض النقاط خاصه في هذه المنطقه اذا
تعتبرها اراضي لبنانيه صرفه استنادا الى
تقسيم الحدود عام 1923 ما بين الانتداب
البريطاني والانتداب الفرنسي والذي
اعتبرها ارضا اللبنانيه رغم ان الاتفاق
الاخر في عام 48 اعتبرت ارضا سوريا وهذه
المنطقه اقول لماذا نقطه اشتعال معظم
الاحداث التي ينفذها حزب الله ضد الجنود
الاسرائيليين تقع في تلال كفر شوبا او في
مزارع وحرب عام 2006 هي كانت ثمره طبيعيه
لهذا الاحتكاك اذا هذا الاحتكاك هو اعتقد
احتكاك دائم ولكنه منضبط يشتغل في بعض
الظروف كان هناك مناورات لها حزب الله في
الجنوب اللبناني
وكانت عمليه محاكاه لمهاجمه مستوطنات جاءت
تصريح وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي الذي تحدث
قبل عده ايام عن ضروره الاستعداد للتعامل
مع اكثر من جبهه اذا هذه المنطقه هي نقطه
احتكاك نقطه اشتعال يتم توضيح بين فتره
واخرى نقطه مشتعله وفي السياق الحالي ما
احتمالات التصعيد في اعتقادك
لا سيتم باحتواء الموقف يعني اعتقد ان
الحدث الذي جرى هو ليس اكثر سوءا مما جرى
الاسبوع الماضي عندما حاولت جرافه
اسرائيليه دفن احد الرعاه بسبب اعتراضه
لها وقامت قوات اليونيفال بانقاذه في
اللحظه الاخيره وتم احتواء الموقف في هذا
اليوم لم يحدث ذلك حدث احتكاك الامر
اللافت ان الجيش اللبناني انتشر ووجه الار
بي جي الى الدباب الاسرائيليه لكن تم
السيطره على الموقف واحتوائه اذا اقول هي
نقطه احتكاك توظف لاغراض سياسيه واغراض
الماء ولكن يتم احتوائها بسرعه ما هي هذه
الاغراض التي تقصدها لواء الدويري
الان هناك عمليه تصعيد من قبل حزب الله
مرتبط بالتصعيد في الملف الايراني هذه
الاحداث هي ارسال رسائل الى الجانب
الاسرائيلي ان اي اشتباك او اي اقتتال مع
ايران حزب الله جاهز لديه 200 الف صاروخ
يغطي جغرافيا فلسطين المحتله ولا تعبث
وتلعبوا بالنار حزب الله جاهز للاشتراك في
اي معركه تاخذها اسرائيل ضد ايران
وبالتالي هذه الاعمال الصغيره هي نوع من
اظهار ان حزب الله يتابع كل صغيره وكبيره
وانه جاهز للرد والتدخل ويجب الابقاء على
معادله الردع هو اسرائيل ايضا كانت قد
صرحت بانها جاهزه لاي حرب في اي جبهه
مؤخرا صرحت بذلك بالتالي هل هي معنيه الان
ببدا حرب في هذه المنطقه
لا اعتقد ذلك وقلنا سابقا بان لا اسرائيل
ولا حزب الله ولا حركات المقاومه في غزه
يرغبوا في تصعيد لان لكل منهم مشاكله ولكن
لا يمكن لاي طرف منهم اي ان يظهر الضعف
مقابل الطرف الاخر لا يمكن لحزب الله ان
يتراجع عن معادله الردع لا يمكن للفصائل
في غزه ان تظهر جانب الضعف والاستسلام ولا
يمكن لاسرائيل ان تقبل ان
تقوم الجبهه الشماليه او الجنوبيه
بابتزازها اذا هي مقاربه خطره ولكنها
مقاربه منضبطه شكرا لك الخبير العسكريه
وليستراتيجيه اللواء فيز الدويري كنت معنا
من عمان